[Applause]
the coolest perk of this job p.s is
getting to meet people you never thought
you'd get to meet and then you get to
talk to them and get paid for it it's
all glad to come and visit with you no
i'm such a fan i think you're so
talented you're so talented i love like
everything you're in um you actually
know jada slay i heard i do oh my
beautiful lady oh so inspiring how do
you know her how do you work together on
9-1-1 oh that's right now come on yeah
[Applause]
have you been able to see a drag show
impression i'm not so i mean i've i've
seen pictures but to see it in the flesh
is exciting i love it and we talked
about you know she would show me videos
but uh
would you show me that uh jump split
death
drop
[Laughter]
you get me alone
and you can do it in that outfit
are you about to make me feel bad about
myself
okay here we go what
[Applause]
i actually your thighs oh my god i hurt
like
just watching that
oh my god that was amazing i did that in
high school once and that was the last
time
thank you
i have never done that and i probably
never will i wanted her to do it on
9-1-1 i would literally have to have so
much alcohol and a doctor for afterwards
yeah yeah yeah like tylenol please that
was amazing thank you yeah and a heating
pad that would hurt um so wait i i have
to ask i heard that your first ever
concert was pretty amazing you want to
tell everybody who that was first ever
oh and what a
come around moment with the jackson 5.
that's amazing yeah
somebody told me that because i always
ask because obviously i'm a musician so
i was asked like what people go see and
that's your first concert yes my sister
and i were in north carolina my poor
uncle he had gotten me us tickets yeah
and they got great tickets because we
were in like the first or second row
we had our little you know bolero jacket
hot pants and samson and delilah sandals
and i swear they looked right at me and
sang the song and it was just great and
then many many many years later when i
decided to become an actress to play
miss catherine their mom oh my god and
she was just she's an absolute delight
what an awesome light and i remember
being at um the image awards and miss
catherine walked by and it was like and
we would sit have lunch and look at the
clouds and talk such a mother yeah such
a you know inspiration and so she
stopped and michael and he turned around
like mom and he came back and he was
like oh
you were wonderful
and i was that that 12 year old
isn't that crazy when stuff like that
happens i was just like oh my god his
hand is in my hand oh that's so cool and
what a i just can't say it enough it's a
very rad first concert i was like i
don't know if anybody can beat that um
but wait so you were just in in puerto
rico right with your sister i was just
there my sister my cousin that was
actually one of her they were her her
job they had raised enough done great
things so they were being awarded by
their ceo janice howard bryant brian
howard and uh just appreciating all the
hard work they were a glorious group of
people and i sort of like
pinched off their vacation tagged along
yeah yeah yeah i would never mind being
that third wheel i'm not like atv and
i've never done that before you've never
been 18. i've never been able that's
like one of my favorite things to do
yes my sister was like you're supposed
to follow the guide i was going around
the mud puddles you know going very
slowly through them because everyone you
know before going everyone had splatter
and mud and yeah and everything and i
had sandals on and white and i'm i'm the
girl that came back from that ride that
you saw before you went out and you're
like what happened to her because i'm
the one that hits all the puddles yeah i
didn't know i'm like i'm like oh i want
to get i don't know what well i do think
they go so fast though because i've done
those tours and i'm like i'm like you go
too fast i want to like see it they go
fast and they're heavy and you're just
trying and you're you know fishtailing
and i love that it's a little scary on a
straightaway a straightaway i mean i'm
mario andretti
no i love that you did that though it's
so fun and it's ziplining in the
rainforest oh wow you know some of the
the guys on you know couldn't speak i
speak a little bit of spanish from you
know torres sanjos de espanol in school
oh my god so hola puppy
like if you couldn't be hotter you had
to start speaking in another language
but i had to give them a little bit
because they're little coconuts they
came up to my cousin's sister and he he
had a machete and he opened the coats
and gave it to him and somehow the
language barrier you know
the sexy name of the machete
[Laughter]
so what's up with your character this
season
oh athena um athena and bobby you know
this of course this hill gore and action
and mayhem and drama the first you know
the first part we for you know in the
fall we left off so it's a lot of family
stuff you know may has been working as a
9-1-1 operator her gap year is over
what's she going to do mom's trying not
to uh you know insert her opinion too
strongly you know but uh athena and
bobby are doing great and
there's this there you know we based a
lot of our stories on real life
issues situations symptoms all of that
which is why it's related fear phobia
and so there's a condition where one of
our characters she absolutely has no
fear you know she douses a man in in
gasoline she's at the top of you know a
station she's about to jump she it just
doesn't register and i'm trying to talk
her down and save her what yeah
so it's some sort of blood condition and
i've never been so thankful for my fear
what's your fear what's your i don't
know oh god i have like i think as a
mother it's always your children if
something happen to your children but
like just in life i don't really want to
say it what if some psycho takes me and
that does it i don't want to say it i
don't want it it's emotional remember
somebody kidnapped me and do my worst
fear and i'll just say it i don't want
to be stranded in the middle of the
ocean just sitting there treading water
i'd rather the shark just come and eat
me and get her done
oh no no no no just take me out like
cause i can tread water for a while i i
don't know i've never been on a on a
cruise before first cruise it's like
we're out here in the middle of the
ocean yeah
and we all know about the titanic i was
like
first thing i do is check for boats are
there enough for all of us or what's
happening yeah yeah i don't like being
in the middle mine is being i don't like
being closed in so like claustrophobia a
little bit
and i remember one time working with um
uh
wes craven you know stream and all of
that like the king of horror couldn't be
a nicer man and he had to be in a in a
coffin
you know but fortunately it was one of
those with a top and a bottom i was like
please leave the bottom open so that my
mind knows i have a warning oh do you i
i actually am claustrophobic i get
closer yeah i never had it until i was
like older and it happened when i was in
a pyramid in egypt and all of a sudden i
was like there's not enough air for all
of us and i'm going to make it yeah so
i've raced out of that thing putting
women in i was
notre dame notre dame in paris oh and
and you know it's an old building so
it's just like oh the stairs over the
stairs these little windows you're like
i wish i was at the cafe having
cappuccino yeah why am i going up here
to the gargoyles yeah and people are
walking slow and you're like
come on no there's not enough air
yeah yeah no i look at the stuff like
that and i'm like so happy i was born
when i was born
i'm like i would not have made it
medieval times um wait i want to ask
about black panther too first of all
just amazing films um but will the queen
get to fight in this next one because i
want you too
really come on
oh she's going she's going to just go on
yeah
[Applause]
it's literally like that is one of the
films that's seen most in my house my
five-year-old son is obsessed
he's obsessed he every halloween he
wants to be black panther oh yeah every
halloween it's so cool
and it's cool like it's i know it's a
superhero thing but it's cool that
like you know to be able to be a
character in these movies that these
kids will grow up just loving and you
get to be a part that's such a cultural
thing that's so not many people get to
be a part of absolutely yeah
queens and kings queens yeah you see
that representation but also like
representation and also good messaging
like it's you know it's it's one step
further i think than when we were
kids yeah i think it's really really
give a lot up to our director and our
writer ryan coogler he i mean such
such a tremendous talent and and
everyone that he he brings on that set
everyone in front of you know in front
of the camera and behind the camera so
impressive and giving a thousand percent
of their gifts and we all have gifts
yeah so it's oh the cast is insane
yeah it's like you see the cast and
you're like okay
it's so amazing so what memories of
chadwick do you have do you have any
great ones uh let's say what was maybe
about
15 years ago i was i was given
thankfully grateful for a honorary phd
from howard university oh wow yeah so i
went there that's amazing both there
you and uh he was he was my guide he was
my student guy like before he was before
anything and everything yeah he was an
actor there he was an actor there what a
full circle moment
did he tell you that whenever he told me
that at the at the opening party at the
premier party and i was like
you cold water
i can't hold water you know but uh he
didn't tell you the whole time and we
sat next to each other every morning in
the makeup chair you know as we're
getting our lines and our accents and
our work together for the day and uh oh
my gosh amazing i would have reminded me
of that i would have had to have been
like what we've been doing
yeah oh my gosh that's so cool though i
love those full circle moments that's
really really cool amazing amazing
[Music]
you